welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar opportunities and
challenges for applying machine learning
in the cannabis space it is presented by
James eaves PhD a professor in the
Department of Management at Laval
University my name is Judy Arak and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events in
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following presentation if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now about further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Eve's
I will now turn the presentation over to
him hi Judy thanks a lot for that
introduction as Judy said I'm a
professor at Laval University and I'm
also an agricultural economist my
specialty is finding ways to integrate
technology and methods into controlled
environmental agricultural facilities to
increase the improve the profitability
and efficiency of growing cannabis I'm
also the head of innovation at Green
Seal cannabis company which is a
licensed producer of cannabis in
Stratford Ontario they use an advanced
vertical growing method to grow cannabis
and are highly rd focused so as they're
ahead of innovation I manage all the R&D
programs and we have a wide range of
program
that we do internally and in partnership
with universities we have genetics
programs projects related automation
horticulture course and recently we
started really interesting one related
to machine learning in partnership with
three universities across North America
and that's what I'd like to talk to you
a little bit about today is just to give
you some insights into the opportunities
and challenges facing people who would
like to apply machine learning to the
agricultural space just to give you some
context like this sophisticated or
advanced green house or indoor growing
facilities manage their environmental
conditions and plant inputs using
management systems in other words that
these systems control precisely control
environmental conditions and things like
how much water and how much water a
plant receives and when the nutrients
the co2 levels and of course to do all
those things they have to continuously
monitor all those factors and
environmental conditions using sensors
so it's these it's the data gathered by
these sensors over a period of time that
create the opportunity to use those data
to train machines either to replace
human tasks by training these machines
by looking at examples of humans doing
these tasks or to train the machines to
actually learn new things that we
weren't aware of new ways to improve
efficiency or profitability and what's
really interesting is that over time
these machines can can can learn as they
gather more data can can learn more ways
or to learn to improve those processes
without human input and that's why we
refer to this as machine learning so
what I want to do today is just go
quickly
go through the machine learning process
to give you insights into how in general
how you build a machine learning method
or machine learning model then talk
about some agricultural applications non
cannabis agricultural applications of
machine learning I'm not aware of any
applications of machine learning that
have been published to relate it to
improving the efficiency or
profitability of growing cannabis I am
aware of some that are you that some
studies that have proposed using machine
learning to identify cannabis in or an
or form for enforcement of laws but I'm
not aware of any out of any research
that's that's specifically designed to
improve the possibility of growing
cannabis so what I'd like to do is just
use these examples to give you some
sense about how it's applied to
agriculture and those examples will be
relevant to cannabis as you'll see and
then finally I'll talk about some
potential opportunities of applying
machine learning to cannabis using
examples from the facility that I work
at the mental model that I like to use
when I think about what machine learning
is is just it's a it's a way it's like
machine learning algorithms are just
question answering machines and of
course I can build a machine to do I can
build I can use lots of different
machines to to do the same task the
difference will be the level of
effectiveness a machine each machine
performs that task and so of course your
goal is to find the machine that works
the best and the machine learning those
those machines those those
question-answer machines to refer to as
models and in order to take you through
the process or to give you some
intuition about the process of building
those models I like to use a simple
typical example of a video streaming
service that wants to make good
recommendations to movie recommendations
to its customers so
they want to build a model that's
capable of answering the question will
this particular question customer like
this movie or not and so what what what
the movie the streaming company will do
is is show that that model or this
machine data in order to build that in
order to create that question answering
machine and refine it over time using
this iterative process we call training
and you'll see that this is exactly this
training process is very intuitive like
the process itself is very intuitive
like for me once if you think about
trying to teach like for instance your
child the to distinguish between ripe
peach and non right peach peaches that
are ready to eat in peaches that aren't
ready to eat you would go through this
process you would first find peaches
that were both ripe and not ripe and
then choose characteristics of those
peaches that you think are correlated
with ripeness for instance you might the
color the smell the texture how firm
they are and you would teach the child
to recognize those characteristics in
order to be its distinguish between the
two classes of peach and at the end you
would show the child peaches that
they've never seen before and ask them
to tell you whether the ripe or not and
that's how you would evaluate the
training process right a training a
machine is what goes through exactly the
same process for instance the first part
of that process
is gathering data all right so if we
stick with our our our video-streaming
example some of that data might include
the genre of the movie the country of
origin how long the movie is a
particular actors how much it costs to
develop is it a high-budget movie or a
low-budget movie right we refer to these
characteristics as features these are
each of the characteristics of the movie
are features then you know there's a
large number of features that you could
consider using and you want to use the
best ones and so that process of picking
the ones that you think are most highly
correlated with this target this this
thing you want to accomplish a question
when the answer is called feature
selection and then finally we want to
tag those characteristics or label those
characteristics with whether or not the
customer liked or disliked the phone of
the movie so at the end your dataset
might look like something that looks
something like this like so imagine that
we picked a hundred movies and we just
decided that two features were important
the number of action films and and the
budget for this particular person and
then each of those each set of features
we labeled whether or not our customer
liked that movie this is obviously data
that would get from their their web
interface then a next phase is splitting
the data into a training and evaluation
data set the training data set we'll use
to actually teach the computer to make
answer that question well given those
features and at the end after it's been
sufficiently trained will go and show
the data the computer new data right for
we which and the data that the machine
hasn't seen before to test how well it
answers questions how well it's been
trained and that the data we draw from
it comes from the evaluation data set
and typically researchers will split
these we'll use about 80% of the data of
their data set for training and a
remaining 20 for evaluation but there's
a whole there's a whole literature based
on the like the different ways of
splitting a data set between training
and evaluation
so within the next in the next step
you'll select a model and the first
thing here I plotted our fictitional
data in this in this figure on the
vertical axis I have the movie budget
and on the horizontal axis I have the
number of action scenes and I've colored
data points red if the person didn't
like the movie and green if they did and
so what I need now is some sort of model
to determine whether what whether or not
when I show a new movie whether or not
the person is gonna like that based on
this training data set we might look at
this data set and say oh well it's just
obvious I don't need a model I'm this
person obviously likes little budget
action films but then if I showed you a
new data point and asked you to classify
it it might be you know they it might be
more challenging than you think you'll
need some sort of rule or some sort of
mechanism for determining whether or not
that's um for guessing whether or not
the client liked this movie or not one
intuitive method might be just to draw a
circle around around a new movie and
decide well if there's if that's if that
circle captures more movies that the
person liked then they disliked I'll
just classify that new movie as a movie
that the person liked right and this is
actually this is actually basically a
common and popular machine learning
model called K nearest neighbors right
like as I said there's lots of different
models that we could use like another
one is that support vector machines work
you actually try to estimate a boundary
between the two groups and depending on
which the what distinguishes these
models it's just served
is their relative performance and the
performance of those models is going to
vary depending on the application for
instance this in this study which I've
cited back here the researchers or the
refute or reviewed a large number of
machine learning vision models that had
been applied to agriculture applications
and they and they use that data to try
to determine which models performed
relatively better on which type of
agricultural applications so this is a
study that I find if you're I find it's
relevant to the cannabis industry also
because as I said these applications are
obviously going to be very similar so
the next step will be going through this
iterative iterative process to actually
train the model to actually do to to get
it in a place where it'll answer that
question as as well as possible and what
I mean by training is actually working
choosing your models and then then
adjusting the parameters of those models
to a point where they answer where they
perform the best for instance staying
with our current example you might
change the shape or of that circle or
the number of movies that circle
captures right and you would change
those parameters until you optimize the
performance of that model in the
training dataset and when you're at the
point where you're satisfied with the
performance of your model that's when
you would take the evaluation data set
and start showing the Machine data
points it's never seen before and asking
it to answer that question and then
recording whether how often it answered
it correctly right so you do that and
and then measure that some there are
different measures of accuracy
and then you would if you're satisfied
with that measure of accuracy then you
could implement the model and if you're
not he might return to the training
process I went through that quickly but
I what the point is of that I think it's
important to understand that process
because when we go and start talking
about the context of can't applying
these to cannabis you'll see that
certain institutional fat features of
the cannabis industry make it
particularly challenging to apply that
process to cannabis all right so now
Rhett I would like to I'm gonna go look
at a couple quick examples of
applications of machine learning and
agricultural sector that are relevant to
cannabis so in this first study the
researchers use a spectral sensing
method to to identify to use leaves
identify if a citrus plant was suffering
from citrus greening greening or which
called Wang long being or hlb disease
which is a which is a pathogen that's
death
absolutely devastating the citrus
industry in Florida and what spectral
sensing is is it's based on the fact
that everything has its own unique sort
of spectral signature so if I shine UV
light on something based on this the
chemical makeup of that substance the
the thing is going to emit wavelengths
back or out from like the plant or leaf
will admit wave lames out in a pattern
that depends on the chemicals and the
plants for instance if you shine UV
light on leaves right based on the
amount of chlorophyll the leaf is
producing
that amount of sugars in the leaf the
oxygen concentration tripping profile
all those things will affect the
particular signature that's emitted from
the plant so what these researchers did
is they trained by by having healthy
leaves our beliefs sort of selected from
healthy plants and leaves selected from
plants that have hlb they they
identified a particular spectral
signature from HL be contaminated plants
and trained their machine to distinguish
those leaves from healthy leaves and if
you look at the picture on the right you
can see why this would that value
because if an HL be infected plant the
leaves look quite similar to a plant and
as a nutrient or magnesium deficiency so
we can imagine that might be difficult
for or challenging for like production
workers to actually make that distinct
that that distinction and of course you
might want to identify lots of different
pathogens right you might just want to
have this more general tool that could
tell you if your plant is healthy or if
it's not and if it's not what's the
particular problem and that's what so
these in this next study these
researchers went and use this
transformation process to to take the
signals at the plants the plants were
admitting when they were when one movie
leg was shined on them this they took
that that spectral signature and
decomposed it so that they could try to
identify use that to build a machine
that could identify multiple different
pathogens including an aphid infestation
and powdery mildew which are two very
common threats to cannabis producers
another valuable piece of information or
producers for farmers is the amount of
yields they can expect to have and at a
given point in time and the distribution
of those yields across their farm that
information allows the producer to plan
labor and things like packaging but it
also by looking at the distribution the
mapping of the yields across the field
it also allows them to get insights into
what's right and what's wrong with their
production techniques in other words
like if I notice that one part of my
farm that yields are much higher than
another part there might be some there's
some spatial component to that like for
the way I'm here gating or my my climate
control and that part of the farm that
would allow me to improve yields across
all the farm right allows me identify
problems and opportunities by looking at
the spatial distribution of yields so in
this study researchers took photos of
use of digital camera and took photos of
plants right of in their peach in a
peach Grove and treating the system the
machine to distinguish between ripe and
and and non ripe peaches and also to
count the ripe ones so that the farmers
that could give the farmer an estimate
of what the yields will be at the
different point of time in the what was
interesting that it's not interesting
but it's important about this is that
they're using a kind of more standard
camera something that you know a grower
might yeah it makes the application more
feasible cheaper more accessible to a
grower so they can just carry a camera
around there and around their field
so like I said there's no those those
studies are relevant to cannabis
obviously can imagine how those studies
are relevant to cannabis there's not
there's none that there's no studies
that I'm aware of
that are published for cannabis at this
point though I know they're happening
like I said I know I know companies that
are working on these algorithms right
now for cannabis and also we're working
on them as well so what I want to do is
I want to talk about some likely ones
and some ones that were working on okay
one of the most obvious ones is just the
optimal growing recipe like I said we're
gathering these in these sort of
advanced growing facilities or gathering
tremendous amounts of data where we're
gathering data on consumer co2 on the
vapor pressure differential how much
light the plants are receiving a
spectrum of that light we're constantly
doing we're using different substrates
and testing different substrates in
different parts of the process we're
also testing different substrates
fertigation of irrigation and nutrient
applications are constantly monitored
and of course the temperature and all
these things will affect the value the
combination things will affect the value
of the yield but those that the actual
relationship you have between those
things and the and the value of yield
will depend on a cultivar Oh also so
training the machine to look at all that
data over time including yield data in
order to identify an optimal growing
recipe for each cultivar would obviously
be very valuable for a grower I wrote
value of yield because the value of the
yield is going to depend on the
particular growers business objectives
for instance it might be yields or it
might be
the characteristics most important might
be the yield it might be the terpene
profile of the plant or it might be tip
which or the THC level and currently in
the market keep the THC little level of
the plant it's probably the largest
driver of the value of that yield this
is a obvious problem and it would be
like it would obviously create a lot of
value for a grower to have to if there
was a machine that could help us
identify the smoke growing recipe but
it's also a really hard problem because
you can imagine all the different
combinations of of all these different
factors you have to gather a lot of data
over a long period of time but you also
the grower you need variations in all
these different variables so that the
machine can learn can see the
differences and learn and so the growers
also gonna have to be actively
implicated in their process and open to
making adjustments to the combinations
of these variables so that the computer
confirm which combination is the most
optimal during the cannabis production
process there are lots of different
quality control steps for instance when
we move what we decide which mothers
were gonna use to create clones you
first you have to look at the health of
the mother to determine whether or not
that mother is healthy enough to provide
healthy clones and enough healthy clones
after you move transplant the clones
from a cloner from the rock wall to the
vegetative stage right the that you
don't transplant all the clones you're
transplanting healthy clones right and
again what's healthy is judgment made by
a person at this point again then when
you transplant plant clones to the
flowering stage I again there's someone
that's saying okay we're gonna we're not
that we're only gonna we're gonna plant
80% of these so the 20% that we don't
plant that
the least healthiest again someone is
it's a it's a quality judgment and just
give you a little context if you're not
familiar with the process because we
know there's lots of variability in the
health of plants say baby plants that we
move to produce flower from we always we
always produce about 20% or 30% more
than we need so that we can select the
healthiest of those of that batch and
this is wasteful takes of time it takes
up space it takes up um it takes up
labor and so if you can find ways to
reduce the necess neccessity or the that
percentage that would create value for
grower one of the most the biggest
bottlenecks in the production process is
trimming we eat like even green sails a
medium-sized facility but every harvest
we have tens of thousands of flowers
that we have to filter through in order
to determine whether they need it
whether they are they pass this quality
control process what happens if is first
you take all the flower and you drop
them into because there's so many of
them you don't hand trim all them you
drop them into a trimming machine and
they come out of the trimming machine
and then someone has to decide whether
or not they go back in the trimming
machine which ones go back in the
trimming machine then after they go
through trimming machine they go on this
these giant tables and then humans go
through them and they decide whether
they need hand trimming right and you
see on the bottom left is an example of
a plant or a flower that needs more hand
trimming because they're still leaves
sticking out of the bud and there's a
stem that sticks out the bottom and so
then all those have to be separated and
then those goes go to people who can
perform the hand trimming until the bud
looks closer to the photo on the bottom
right which is a pass right they can
imagine this is a very like this a long
process like I said one of the biggest
max in the production process and
because there's so many flowers you it's
it's it's difficult to have well-trained
quality control people inspect them all
so a lot of it is just its production
associates who are making judgments on
their own and you can imagine they're
like they want to get through this
process as fast as possible so there's
this incentive to you know to kind of
push some of these buds these flowers
through the process quickly so surely
someone's gonna develop a mechanism for
doing that quality control using a
machine learning process and image
recognition process to identify these
characteristics those features and and
notify the grower that these these
flowers need to be me trimmed or hand
trimmed or to just handle the process
itself just do the just direct those
flowers back to the trimming process
then this next example is something I
find really fascinating is this concept
of peak ripeness it's at this point it's
a judgment call about when the master
grower decides when to harvest I mean
some facilities they they have a kind of
strict sort of schedule for harvesting
in other words they say okay every every
70 days we put the flowers this cultivar
in flowering and after 70 on day 70 we
harvest regardless of the the ripeness
of the plant but many look for visual
signals have mass many master growers
look for visual signals that they think
are correlated with what they call peak
ripeness and what peak ripeness
generally is is maximum THC levels again
it kind of it matters it depends on the
actual business objective it could be it
could be something else but typically
there
harvesting at the point where they think
THC levels or or yields are the highest
and what happens is that if you get past
a certain point the maximum THC point
THC starts degrading is CBS is CBN
Canada null and this is not this is just
another compound cannabis compound and
it has its own effects but they're not
psychoactive effects so they're there so
they're more sedate ofthere often more
associated with pain management or what
what growers are referred to as couch
lock it's just like this sedated heavier
effect on the user which some people may
like but the lower THC level reduces the
value of the plant since generally the
market puts the highest value on THC so
the way growers right now determine
whether a plant is ripe or not is they
look at the stigmata in the trichomes
so you've looking at top right image
those little white leaves those baby
white leaves are sticking out of the
plant that kind of look like hairs are
the stigmata and when some percentage of
those flip to from a white to a brown
color or a brownish color usually around
80 60 to 80 percent the grower will say
okay that the heart this this this plant
is ready and they harvest another
typical method it's a look at the
trichomes right if you look at the
bottom right hand the bottom right hand
photo those little hairs that stick out
from the plant are the trichomes if you
look at the big plant on the big bud on
the on the left hand side all that sort
of white snowy stuff are that is that
those are trichomes and so when those
trichomes switch from that clear color
that you to have more
creamy sort of color that's another
visual indication that's generally
believed to be correlated with maximum
THC I have no idea if that's if that's
the case or not I haven't personally
done that research but that's the that's
the belief so again surely this would be
something that'd be very useful to a
canvas grower would be a machine look to
train a machine to identify visual
characteristics of a plant in order to
help the grower determine when what is
peak ripeness and again that's gonna be
we're gonna that's that training the
data from that is not only what you see
in this photo but you also have to
correlate these they'll also have to
gather data on the chemical profile of
the plant so you can correlate these
visual characteristics with a chemical
profile that's most desired by the
grower one of the biggest mysteries to
me personally is a drying and curing
process especially the curing process so
at the after plants are harvested
they're dried in here we see they're
there they're just hung up and dry just
different drying methods but in this
case they're just they hang them up and
dry for some period of time you know
it's a few days to over a week then
after they're dried those buds the
flowers are placed in sealed containers
and then cured and what and with that
curing process is their place and sealed
containers and once a day or they're
those concealed containers are opened to
release the co2 in the container and
then closed again and somehow that this
cheering and drying process depending on
how it's done affects the flavor and the
usability of the plant and the store
ability of the plant at the end I say
it's a mystery to me because important
securing I
I personally hadn't I really have no
idea what's going on is something that's
I've you know I've tried though I've
tried to learn about it personally by
looking at the curing literature for
different plants like tobacco it's doing
something and it's surely affecting the
quality of the final product and how how
exactly it's doing that is a mystery and
it's something that could have a lot of
value to growers by giving us more
insights into what's happening for
instance there's a lot of variability
and just if you look at these plants
right these in this in this picture you
imagine like you know dozens of these
racks in this giant room everything
drying and the consistency of that room
is different and so these plants dry
depending where they are they dry
different different rates and depending
F their level of maturity when they they
started as drying and curing process the
effectiveness of that dry maturing
process is different so gathering that
data and allowing people allowing and
training a machine to correlate those
factors with this target at the end of
whatever it is of just of height well a
homogeneous lee dried product or a
product that's that can store for a long
time or that has a certain flavor or
high THC levels again would add a lot of
value so you can see at each step of
this process of propagation vegetation
flowering drying and curing there's all
these environmental factors that impact
the final result of that stage and we
know very little about those those
specific impacts of those those
combination of factors so I think this
is a big area for where machine learning
could add a lot of value to the Kansas
production process now I talked mostly
about production applications but
there's obviously lots of applications
that are more closely related to retail
for instance there's more
Stane future product demand like what
strains will be popular six months from
now there's tremendous amounts of data
out there user in the CRM systems of
these companies or on the web that you
could use to actually make better help
people make these producers make better
predictions about what strains are gonna
be demanded six months from now and how
much so that you can they can use that
information to determine their
production schedules of course inventory
management we have you know there's
again we're gathering all this data we
know what's coming in to our facilities
we know what we're using especially
because of the this very highly
regulated nature of cannabis in Canada
where were we record everything so that
all that data could be used to improve
the effectiveness of these companies and
managing their inventories what should
they set prices at again how much should
you charge for particular strains this
would depend on the popularity strain
the demand trends in the market another
very important valuable application
potential application machine-learning
work all across North America right now
they're opening stores really rapidly
retail stores what are this is something
that machine learning is being used for
right now in in other sectors like where
McDonald's opens up its next door or
someone that is it's not a rare or
Starbucks it's not a random decision
they're using machine learning to
optimize their déplacement distribution
of stores right that how those same
methods can be used to help can users
locate their stores and what products
should they put in those stores every
week or every month you know these
products are changing what is the OP
like combination and curation products
in a store and on over any giving period
again another really interesting machine
learning that potential machine learning
application finally I just want to talk
about some challenges of applying
machine learning to the Cannabis state
space so if you reflect on those those
those six steps that we go through in
order to build and train a machine
learning model you'll see why it's
challenge cannabis poses particular
challenges to machine learning
entrepreneurs and researchers first
there's this really interesting thing
about the cannabis industry it's
extremely secretive and that I I believe
just is a legacy effect of you know
decades of trying to avoid prosecution
is that this there's a real culture of
secrecy right it's not like other
Agriculture's not like Tomatoes if you
know many of these producers are they
hide they want to hide a lot of their
methods they're very apprehensive about
sharing data with companies because they
feel like they're gonna reveal a secret
about that makes that this
differentiates their production from our
capacity from an or from another
companies so it's something you'll have
to deal with those it's very it will be
very challenging to form partnerships
with these companies and and or it's
gonna be more challenging to get a
cannabis producer to form partnerships
with a outside company to train these
models than say a tomato grower another
thing is that even if they're open they
see the value of of this these machine
learning models to their business
I mean if they want to do it there
they're not focused on that right now
right now producers are kind of trapped
in this this land grab the main sort of
industry focus is getting this big
getting as many permits in as much
surface area as possible and it's very
hard to convince management to devote
resources to research and development at
this point even though they may talk
about it right now companies are
primarily focused on just increasing
their capacity no matter what the
efficiency is they're making lots of
making lots of decisions are not are not
are not necessarily efficient from a
production standpoint but it allows them
to get more capacity online faster right
so another thing is just catching a
producer's focus is very difficult in
this market right now and finally we
talked about so we see the gathering
data is gonna be challenging but also we
mentioned that process that feature
selection is very important what
features what characteristics what
variables are gonna be the most
important in answering the particular
question you want to answer but because
cannabis has been you know illegal and
still is illegal in the United States
even I'm more federally at least like
researchers the United States still
can't do research on cannabis and
researchers in Canada just started
there's extreme lack of scientific data
to help us decide what what features
will be the most important we're
actually specifying these machine
learning models so on all in all this is
the swipe sites its cannabis is a
challenging space right now to apply
machine learning methods but at the same
time it's also the sector that has the
most money and and to suspend on on this
on this sort of this sort of Rd so it's
surely gonna happen I mean it is
happening so so I encourage you to like
- I definitely encourage you to invest
time to learning more about how applying
these models to this space if you have
any questions please send them to me I'm
very happy to answer whatever questions
you have on this topic or related topics
and I appreciate your time thank you
thank you dr. eaves for that informative
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible as a final reminder our
speaker will follow up with any
questions you'd submitted via email that
is all for now thank you for joining us
and we will see you next time goodbye